the Joe Rogan experience it's very
difficult to get comics cancelled unless
they're doing something I know you gotta
get I mean even Z's which I think he got
a [ __ ] terrible deal like what
happened with him was terrible it sound
like a bad date it sounds like one
person's account of it and he didn't
give his account of it and you know he
just tried to stay supportive of me too
and all that jazz but I got devastated
that was wrecked by that yeah really
wrecked and his special is a great
indication of it you see his recent
special took a giant apology I haven't
seen it yet but I mean he's a funny guy
and he didn't get cancelled he's still
doing shows and everything but this is
Lucy Kay he's still doing shows but
those guys are an example Louie more so
right he's an example because people are
protesting no one's protesting disease
you know he had a bad date yeah but no
one but Louie to this day still getting
protested like he's like people show up
at his shows they print every time he
does a show somewhere they print are who
care he's fine I don't care you don't
care about him you don't just like he's
fine he'll be fine yeah I mean like but
emotionally sure hmm you don't care I
just like emotionally I think he's gonna
be fun I think it's all like you're
gonna upset some people they're gonna
protest but it's not gonna affect your
ticket sales or how much people love you
and he knows that and he's gonna be
quite all right it's not the people that
do love it it's the people that hate him
it's like there's always gonna be a
certain amount of people that do love
you even if you're a terrible person
yeah if you're like look Donald Trump is
one of the things that's fascinating
about him to me is that he's the king of
the [ __ ] like he's an self-avowed
[ __ ] it's very obvious that he's an
[ __ ]
and then other [ __ ] like fine
they've got an [ __ ] speaking for us
and they want to wear sunglasses inside
[ __ ] I mean this is what he attracts all
right so even if you're an [ __ ]
you're going to get a bunch of people
who love you there's just if you're in a
public eye
people choose cult leaders right they
don't choose them for their positive
qualities they get sucked into this idea
of this person liking the
and being on a team with this person and
if that person is a strong person it's
even more intoxicating Donald Trump's a
strong person
celebrities are strong people
celebrities are famous like I you know
everybody hates you Louie but I support
you
there's you're going to have those what
you've done there's people out there
that still that show up at our Kelley's
trial and they have new signs and say we
support you those [ __ ] knew what they
were in for but really this is yeah this
is something that's going on right now
to this day it's because people get
incredibly drawn to someone who is in a
position of fame and power like like a
Donald Trump or or anybody and Louie's
one of those two so it's it's not that
the people who love him don't always
love him and people who love Louis
before and they forgive him for what
he's done but it's gonna be people that
don't and those people that don't they
write articles and just like if he reads
them it's just like burns on you it
hurts you it's like and he's a super
sensitive guy you know all this stuff
like it's like he's gonna be fine
yes but it's still it's not devastating
yeah but didn't he cause a little bit of
devastation in some people's lives
perhaps for sure so for sure I for and I
and and I really think like the the
women the angry people who don't like
him and earn are going to shows wouldn't
have gone to them anyway and yet it's
gonna be to get that Google Alert for
your name when when you know one out of
ten articles is maybe negative about you
but he's doing alright I mean like I
talked to him after it one night at the
Comedy Cellar
I me told me some examples of things
that have been said to him in public
like cuz I just asked him I was like
what has it been like for you this is
right when he came out of hiding and he
told me some stories of things that had
happened in public where a woman once
whispered in his ear you [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] like at a you know he's at a
store or something and then another one
where just a woman blatantly in the
street was like [ __ ] you you know and it
was like oh my [ __ ] god this is a
nightmare for you walking outside your
house but and I'm like just so this is
easy though those only two times of the
whole year and I was like oh okay well
that seems manageable any good
he says but ten times a day people are
still asking for my picture an autograph
so very good so I don't think he's
suffering that much and I don't think he
deserves to suffer that much I'm just
saying I think as many people hate him
as maybe would have anyway because no
one can be famous for too long without
people hating them you know he said a
big one was the big one was that
parkland thing that joke that he made
they got released he said that that
really really [ __ ] him up the response
to that because it was after you know he
had just starting to stand up again
after ten months off and then he did
that joke about the park lands from
harvest about like why are they
interesting and because you pushed a fat
kid in front because you survived it's
like you're laughing see it's a [ __ ]
up thing that someone would say at a
comedy club when you take that out of
context right now then people get angry
at it but that is a classic louis c.k
line I mean that sounds exactly like we
would have reinforced before this whole
thing 100% now he's walking a fine line
you can't also the very beginnings the
embryonic stages of a bit in that bit
cuz monster bit totally yes it you're so
right that was the first incarnation of
that but yeah no stand up at all for ten
months and he's got this bit and he's
working on it and he's got an angle the
angle is why are we these survivors just
because they survive doesn't mean
they're interesting yeah that's that
does true love it it is true great bit
it could have been an amazing bit but
some [ __ ] how to record it and then
put it on YouTube and then you got guys
like Judd Apatow yelling out about it
like is as if this is like Louie's final
statement on the subject and it's this
especially by other comics like that I
found that whole thing to be so [ __ ]
up I was like you know what a bit is
yeah and you know when someone's trying
like don't you ever try man I've said
some stuff on stage reg I even say to
the crowd listen that didn't come out
right
it was first don't please don't tell
anyone that I just said that you all be
just cool of course so I I definitely
understand that and I understand
and saying things that make people feel
really sad and angry and they feel hurt
by it and they write mean things to me
saying that I've hurt their feelings and
it feels shitty and when people hate you
I feel so I do feel for him that way I
do and is why I asked him like what is
it like you're the most beloved and then
you were hate I mean that's gotta
[ __ ] suck let's go and he said he
would have gone done that he would have
gone to Africa to disappear wherever you
know somewhere to disappear but his kids
he couldn't leave yeah and so he just
had to sit around with it so I gotta be
super hard I sympathize or I can
empathize with that for sure and that
would suck
[Applause]